-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everyone.
My next guest is a Democratic
Senator from New Mexico.
His new book,
"The Way Forward: Meeting
the Challenges of a New America"
is on shelves now.
Please welcome to the show,
Senator David Jimenez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
So great to have you here today.
-Thank you for having me, sir.
-So I have a lot
to talk to you about.
But before that, I heard
that you might actually have
something that you want to make
an announcement about.
-That's right, Seth.
I would like to
formally announce
that I am running for President
of the United States.
-Well, that is very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very, very exciting.
-Thank you.
It is exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is exciting stuff.
You know, we have some real
challenges to face in America.
Some of our most dire ones yet.
And I believe
I have the solutions.
-That's amazing,
Senator Jimenez.
And now that you're entering
what is a very --
let's be honest, a very crowded
Democratic field,
can you explain why
you've chosen to run now?
-Seth, the American people need
someone to fight for them
based on their interests,
and lead them to a new day.
-And I'm sorry -- who are you?
-I'm Senator Christine Packard,
and I'm running for President
of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can --
You can read about it
in my new book,
"Fighting for a New Day:
Fighting the Good Fight
for a Good America."
-Oh, okay. Well --
This is a little awkward.
This doesn't really
work that well
if there are two people
at the --
-Seth, I'm sorry,
but we need to usher in
a new America
with what I am calling
a "New American Century,"
filled with promise for
a new century for Americans.
This is why I'm running for
President of the United States.
-Uh-huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can read it in my book,
"A New Century: Making a New
America for a New Century."
[ Laughter ]
-I got to say, it was already
such a crowded field,
and now there are
so many people running,
I'm having trouble
keeping track of everyone.
Is anyone else running?
-We are.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Well, like, just
in interest of time,
could you guys explain
your platforms together?
-Seth, I am the...
-Father of three wonderful...
-Mother of two beautiful...
-...children, and I believe...
-the future
is worth fighting for.
-It's worthwhile to fight for
the future.
-Right now, we are more divided
than ever.
-Our nation is more polarized
-...but I believe I have the
strength and the fortitude...
-...courage and determination
to lead us...
-...to take us...
-...forward, together.
This is why I'm running
for President of the
United States of America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can read about it
in my new book...
-"Becoming the Future..."
"Changing the Present..."
-"How to Change the Present..."
-"How to Alter the Past..."
-"...And Abandon the Past."
-"...And Become the Future."
[ Laughter and cheering ]
-All right, you know,
there are a lot of you.
I'm having trouble keeping you
all straight.
Ultimately it's up to
the voters to decide,
so maybe it would be a good idea
to turn it over to the audience
for a question -- anyone?
-I have a question, Seth.
-Yes, go ahead.
-Seth, America
is at a crossroads.
We have to decide whether
we want to go forwards
into the future or backward
into the past.
[ Laughter ]
I believe I am the one
to lead us forward.
[ Laughter ]
This is why I'm running for
President of the United States!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Read about it in my new book,
"Choosing the Future:
How to Abandon America's Past
and Move Forward to its Future."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man, there's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's some more people here
with some more books,
I just noticed, so, uh...
No offense, but I really don't
want to hear another person
say they're
running for president.
-I'm running for president!
-Oh, man.
-I think there is no way with --
there is no one with the
experience that I have to bring
to the White House.
That is why, until --
with the two remaining years
before I die...
-Oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
-...I am running for President
of the United States!
Read about it in my book!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm Old."
-"I'm Old."
-Your book --
Your book is called
"I'm Old"?
-I'm extremely old, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. Look, I think
I'm going to end this.
I don't know if we're
actually getting
any new information here.
-Seth, I'm running because
I believe in
bipartisan solutions that work.
-Work because America needs
a leader.
-A leader who will put
middle-class Americans --
-Americans ahead of
special interests.
-You know what, that was
very good, you guys.
I just think --
Oh, my goodness! Uh...
Let me guess. You're --
You're running
for president, too?
-Seth, it is
with some regrets
that I am announcing that I am
suspending my campaign to be
President of the United States.
-Oh, I didn't even know
you were running, but --
-Words cannot express how
grateful I am to all of you,
my true friends.
-Oh, I'm sorry, you're out, too?
-My true friends who helped me
in this fight.
-No! Not you, David Jimenez!
[ Laughter ]
-It's clear that my past
was too difficult
for us to overcome.
-And the numbers just weren't
working our way.
-While I believe in
what we fought for,
I also believe I am too old.
[ Laughter ]
-The American people must make
a decision that represents
our shared ideas.
-Our shared ideals
of leading America
to a brand-new future
and away from our past.
-You can read about it
in my new book,
"Clearing the Path:
Abandoning My Past
as a Candidate for America's
Future as a Country."
-Okay, I'm sorry. I am
just having a difficult time
keeping straight which one
of you has dropped out so far.
So, quick head count. Who is
still running for president?
[ Laughter ]
Does anyone want --
Does anyone --
[ Applause ]
Anyone interested
in vice president?
-[Bleep] no.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-Watch the language.
You are very old!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The 2020 Democratic candidates,
everyone.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."